great so I'll be talking today about the
history of crypto art but uh before I
get in just a quick background about me
so as mentioned I was one of the
co-founders of the Stanford blockchain
Club
um back then it was like why only a
dozen of us and it's like pretty crazy
to see how the club has grown
significantly since now there's a class
so it's really good to be back
um I got into crypto I guess my freshman
year I wrote my freshman power paper if
you're an undergrad you know what power
is I wrote my freshman power paper on
ethereum this is like right when
ethereum launched
um and since then since College I
I have one confirmation which is 130
million dollar seed fund
um we've made a lot of big nft
Investments such as leading the seed
round of openc in 2018. um we also have
a nft fund now so not only do we invest
in early stage projects in the crypto
space we also like buy jpegs and
artworks directly and lastly I just want
to mention that I built a personal
website called cryptoart.io which it
basically Aggregates all the nft art
sales across different marketplaces so
it's really cool when artists can see
all their sales in one place
so without further Ado
um
I use before we get into nfts I just
kind of want to talk about how digital
digital artists make money so you know
you're going to be an artist that
um you you don't um create drawings or
paintings but like you just have a large
Instagram portfolio and you have like
hundreds of thousands of followers and
like how do you make a living as a
digital artist
um and before adapts there were a couple
ways to do so
um the first one obviously is to sell
prints so this is an artist named
Etienne Krauss
um and selling prints is like kind of
like selling posters like you might sell
them for like a couple hundred dollars
each but these prints they never
garnered a lot of money because
um they're like you're selling posters
so you're only selling copies of the
artworks rather than the original
authentic one which is what the
collector wants so it's like selling a
poster of the Mona Lisa versus like the
actual Mona Lisa itself like one is
worth much more than the other
um and the other way that artists make
money is through commissions and this
can range from things like uh creating
album art for musicians so like there
are a lot of musicians that create a new
album uh they need an artist to design
the art of the album art uh and they'll
earn like probably like 500 to a couple
thousand for Designing the album art
um and if you're a really well
established artist or Design Studio then
you can get like bigger clients like
Fortune 500 companies so this is one of
my favorite Interior Design Studios
called six and five and they just in
2019 they had a really good big um
collaboration with Microsoft to design
all the wallpaper art for the Microsoft
Surface Microsoft Surface
um and you know these uh big design gigs
can range from like a couple thousand
dollars to tens of thousand dollars of
dollars
um so like all in all artists are
usually making money from selling prints
or doing Commission
um but what I really want to get into is
that nfts are a new business model for
digital artists so not only do they make
money from selling prints and doing
commissions they can also sell
individual artworks like how you would
sell paintings uh so it kind of
revolutionizes the whole way like
creators make money in this digital
world is
uh before we were kind of in this
patronage business model where you make
money from having a patron like
Microsoft and then now you can be an
independent Creator or you sell an
Instagram photo as an nft and that can
be worth like a lots like thousands tens
of thousands of dollars
um
and nft solves like the right click save
as problem that people talk about for
jpegs because collectors know this is
the original version that was minted
from the artist uh and that's the one
that's worth a lot of money
so um I want to talk a bit about the
early nft history before crypto Arts so
um
this is like kind of not really talked
about much but
um you know crypto punks wasn't the very
first nft there were a lot of attempts
at nfts before that you know starting
back with Bitcoin so you know colored
coins was a thing uh in Bitcoin in the
early days basically you would trace a
Bitcoin from like when it was minted
um like kind of in the Genesis block and
make these Bitcoin like non-fungible
where like certain Bitcoin are worth
more than others because they came from
they were minted in certain ways came
from certain addresses and like that was
kind of the first attempt at making you
know Bitcoin non-fungible and applying
that concept to nfts and then we have a
slew of other projects um no starting
with counterparty which is a you know
Bitcoin side chain that's enabled like
nft functionalities and you have early
projects built on counterparty like you
know spells of Genesis more trading
cards we have Pepes and rare Pepes uh
eventually migrated from Bitcoin to
ethereum so where Pepes was really one
of the first nft projects that preceded
crypto punks
um and then the whole Space really
started
um well really like kind of people think
of crypto punks as like the first
um brand name nft project and that
started back in June 2017
um and this was at the time when you
know the ERC 721 standard was invented
it was still erc20s so uh it was kind of
this hacky way of having nfts in a
fungible he's using like the fungible
token standard and base if you aren't
familiar with crypto punks is basically
a collection of 10 000 profile pictures
each with you know different unique
character traits in their avatars you
know some traits are more rare than
others like alien punks zombie punks
um ape punks are worth like much more
than others because there's only a very
few number of those
um and
then we get to January 2018 and this is
when the ERC 721 standard was finally
invented and this is uh kind of the
first big nft standard and it was
invented by Dapper Labs which is the
company behind cryptokitties so like I
said before before
um 721 like all these nft projects we're
trying to use hacky ways of creating
um fungible tokens like ethereum Ico
tokens and using those for nfts but now
there's finally a standard uh for nfts
and that's really kicked off a lot of
new projects uh building on the standard
so now we got went through the early nft
history let's talk a bit about crypto
art so crypto art is like really a
sub-sector of nfts and you know a lot of
people kind of lump everything that's
nft that has to do with art but there's
a lot more to nfts that's just art
there's you know music there's gaming
there's like IP rights
um and crypto art was like really one of
the first
um verticals within nfts one of the
first niches uh really kind of got all
got a big Community early on
um so the artist uh sorry The Collector
Jason Bailey who's goes by Art gnome he
was really the first person to talk
about crypto R and even coined the term
and you know on the screen here this is
the formal definition of crypto art
um but Jason Bailey is a guy who's uh
he's been collecting super early uh he's
he was also into uh like kind of
traditional art before he got into
crypto and was writing a lot about the
potential of you know blockchain Tech
and how that can be used in the art
world
um so he coined the term crypto art
um and shortly thereafter
um the first crypto art platform emerged
uh which was super rare
um so around April uh that's when the
first uh piece of cryptar got minted and
it's called AI generate a new portrait
the artist is an artist named Robbie
Bharat who goes by video drone Robbie
bro actually used to live uh right next
to Stanford I think he was like
somewhere in Palo Alto Menlo Park he now
moved to Amsterdam but he was like kind
of this early AI artist who was
experimenting with a lot of different
things came across super rare decided to
Mint one of his Gan art pieces and you
know Gan stands for a general generative
adversarial networks so it's it's really
popular now with stable diffusion but
basically you take uh you take an image
that's a seed you feed it through the AI
algorithm and you see like what are the
intermediate steps and then you take
that and then use that as your artwork
so he was like four or five years to
this trend before kind of stable
diffusion and like the current open AI
hype like made it really cool
so uh back in April 2018 uh he sold this
piece for uh 0.46 eth which at the time
was 177
um so no that was a big deal at the time
because it showed that people were
willing to pay at least something for
nfts
um but fast forward a few years later
and then we won confirmation we actually
bought this artwork
um we bought it for 100 eth which is
112k at the time so that's a 217x
increase from the initial sale price so
a video drone Robbie Brock sorry art
gnome got a pretty big windfall from
that not only from that sale but also
all the intermediary collectors that the
uh the piece changed hands through
um
and I think this will be uh kind of one
of the pioneering pieces in like our
history textbooks just for the fact that
it was the first piece of crypto art
minted on chain
um and there's actually another uh fun
story in the early crypto art history
um so there's a story of the Lost
Robbies uh so this was around you know I
think June July yeah July 2018 uh so
this was at a conference in London where
you know super rare was talking about
uh they're like kind of pitching
Christie's and like all these Boomer
traditional art collectors about the
promise of nfts and cryptar and like
obviously like kind of the 300 attendees
that attended most of them didn't really
get it
um and as part of their presentation and
they've had these gift bags where there
was a QR code and you could scan it uh
to claim a piece of Robbie Barack crypto
art and obviously you know most people
when you pick up these QR codes and gift
bags from conferences you just throw
them away immediately but the lucky 12
people who actually did claim their
Robbie Bratz
um those pieces sell for six figures
today
um and since all the others haven't been
claimed it's highly likely that the
remaining 288 are lost forever so
encrypt our lore uh those are called The
Lost Robbies and you know you can see
here in this uh in this tweet
um a lot of these different uh pieces
those are different variations of the
Lost Robbies that are lost forever so
that seems like a kind of fun anecdote
from the early history
um and another piece of early crypto our
history is this artist named x copy so
um so the fifth to 16th artworks uh
minted on super rare were all by x copy
um and all 12 of these pieces
um they're worth a lot today because uh
one of the features of the blockchain is
it time stamps uh when nfts or like when
any transaction happens uh and that's
another beauty of the blockchain is that
it's immutable ledger so you can't go
back in history and like change those
time stamps and like that's kind of the
advantage that's super rare in these
early artists have is they have the
advantage of being first so they always
have this good narrative that refers to
this industry
um here's the proof on the chat on the
blockchain that we mentioned these
artworks early and like no other no
other new artists can replicate this
because we came here first so like each
of these pieces will sell for about six
to seven figures
um and you know these are 12 like the
most valuable pieces of crypto are just
because uh they were some of the very
first uh pieces minted on chain
um and that also like ties to this point
um which is the second value prop of of
like why crypto art matters why having a
blockchain is powerful is the blockchain
provides uh provenance and you know I
talked a bit about the time stamping the
other thing is uh
just being able to trace ownership from
the artist like through all the series
of collectors as they keep uh reselling
the as they keep reselling the pieces to
like who the current owner is and you'd
be surprised how like our fraud is
actually a really big problem in the
traditional art World especially when
you have like artworks that are kind of
hidden in this like Swiss Warehouse that
are used for like money laundering for
tax evasion and it's just changing hands
constantly through a series of
paperworks but no one can really tell
um exactly which hands this artwork
changed through and there isn't really
um a ledger that traces the history uh
versus having a blockchain it's all
transparent you can see who exactly the
artist did a primary sale how much all
the subsequent secondary sales are and
who the current collector is
um
and the other part that what I talked I
talked about a bit is because of these
immutable time stamps that the
blockchain provides
um it creates something known as the
Lindy effect
um which is basically the notion that
the longer something's been around the
more valuable it is and like the more
secure it is and this is why the early
artists pieces are valuable because they
were first to the category and they've
been around for a long time and this is
also why you know people talk about nfts
minted on other blockchains like Solana
or tazos and like this is why ethereum
nfts command a premium to Solana and
Taylor's nfts is because ethereum was
first and there's a stronger security
guarantee and that's why they're more
valuable and you can also say the same
thing with other marketplaces like an
artist will mint nfts across lots of
different marketplaces not just super
rare but there's also no Foundation
Nifty Gateway known origin makers place
like the list goes on but the reason
reason why the super rare nfts will sell
for more compared to all the other
marketplaces is because super rare was
first it has kind of this premium brand
and artists want to get curated want to
get listed on super air and collectors
will pay a premium for a super nft and
this all ties to the Lindy effect
um and the last thing I'll say about
like why the blockchain matters for art
is like programmatic royalties
so earlier
um
you know why I talked about this Robbie
Barat piece uh that sold for 177 dollars
and in the primary sale because of a
super rare's artist royalty system
Robbie brawl actually earned uh ten
thousand dollars roughly ten thousand
dollars from the most recent sale in
just an artist royalties and that's
really powerful for artists uh because
you could have an artist that becomes
super big and their collectors will be
able to flip or like resell something
for much more like down the road but the
artists capture in in the traditional
art world the artist captures none of
that value uh but now with our artist
royalties the artist uh gets to capture
the value of their artists artworks
appreciating not just the collector
um and this is you know really
beneficial for early super rare artists
you know I talk about Robbie brought
um you know x copy one of the other the
other early super artists he's earning a
lot more from
from royalties because you know back in
the early days these pieces were only
selling for a couple hundred dollars and
you know now from artists royalties
um they're making 10 to 100 times more
than that just from the world he's alone
uh so we talked a bit about uh Fine Art
uh which Fine Art was really the first
uh sub-genre of crypto art that really
emerged uh but kind of in parallel there
was another genre of crypto art called
generative Arts
uh so first uh what exactly is
generative art so
um it's a class of digital art where
artists use a computer to introduce
Randomness as a partial part of the
creation process
um and you know here's a quote from snow
snow fro who's the founder of art blocks
who talks about uh generative art how
this is revolutionary because it enables
a new art form that like wasn't possible
before
uh so the first uh piece of generative
art was or the first genitive art
collection was in created in April 2019
called Auto glyphs and this was created
by the same team that created crypto
punks
um
is it's basically uh it's an addition of
512 pieces uh created by smart contract
code and I'll get into the code
um in a bit but basically you seed it
with a random number generator and then
you hash it to create some random value
and then based on the value you give it
instructions like kind of a bunch of if
statements uh as you Loop through the
hash through the hash values uh and that
will tell the um that will tell the the
code to print out certain ASCII uh
characters and then when you piece that
together you create this entire artwork
which is called an auto glyph
um you know and this is this is uh kind
of the code that I was talking about
earlier so
um you know you pass in the function you
pass in the seed uh you pass an ID which
converts to the seed and the seed is
created through entropy from the
blockchain so that can be things like
you know block number uh timestamp and
that entropy is used to create a random
hash value
um and then from the hash value uh you
can see in like kind of the bottom half
of the code you see a bunch of
if statements and through each if
statement it tells um like it
concatenates a piece of ASCII
um based on like what the hex value is
and then once you iterate through all
these uh characters and that's how you
create the entire Auto glyph
so autoglyphs was the first generative
art project but generative art didn't
really take off until a project called
Arc blocks came along and this is you
know late 2020
um so art blocks was founded by uh Eric
Calderon who's also known as snowfro so
Eric was actually a prolific artist
before he got into crypto and
blockchains and generative arts and he's
been doing this you know off chain using
other techniques and he decided like why
don't I bring this technique on chain
and create this art platform called Art
called Art blocks and he minted the
since he's an artist himself he minted
the very first art blocks uh collection
called uh chromie squiggles so you know
as you can see here
um there's a lot of different uh
variations of squiggles uh each with
different uh Rarity characteristics
and you know as these are minted it's
using the entropy of the blockchain
decide okay token number one is going to
be this say a standard a squiggle token
number two is going to be a fuzzy
squiggle and so on so forth until you
reach uh say 10 000 swiggles
um and this is all randomly generated by
the blockchain and it's it's a unique
art form enabled uh by the blockchain
because
um of the entropy associated
um so chromey squiggles was like the
first um art blocks project and uh since
then there's been a couple hundred art
blocks projects and two of the most
notable ones are ringers and fidenzas so
ringers is created was created by
Dimitri cherniak who is also another
prolific generative generative artist
before nfts and crypto came along and as
you can see here it's basically a bunch
of uh pegs and lines and colors and kind
of the orientation of these pegs and
lines and colors is like created by
entropy which certain ringers are worth
more than others because they're more
rare and fidenzas is similarly another
uh project by Tyler Hobbs who's
um
a big prolific generative artist and
it's a series of tiles uh created uh
through entropy and you know I think the
floor price now for ringers is around uh
40 eighth ish and then for forenses it's
like around 70 East uh so like you know
these were you know only uh I think they
were like Sub sub one eth at the time
they were minted and since then uh
collectors see generative art as a
valuable uh store of value and that's
why the floor price has increased by so
much
um and so you know we had these uh early
art projects um like you know with super
rare uh art blocks Auto glyphs crypto
punks uh but art was still like pretty
crypto R was still pretty confined to
crypto native so like you know only only
people who really uh understood
um the value of crypto uh we really
understood it uh believed in the
potential of cryptar and like crypto
didn't really go mainstream until uh
this guy came along
um
and this guy's name is people uh who's
well people is is a kind of Alias name
but his real name is Mike winkelmann and
uh he was actually he's actually the
first like very well-known artist
outside of crypto uh to finally learn
what nfts are and decide to Mint
something
um in crypto so even before he got into
nfts he already had over a million
Instagram followers uh and his kind of
claim to fame is uh he minted uh he's
one of the most prolific uh VFX artists
uh so what that is is basically it
stands for visual effects uh use a piece
of software called Cinema 4D and that's
it's kind of like photoshop-ish but you
create all these uh 3D graphics with a
different
uh models like you know figurines heads
you can see in like a screenshot in the
bottom right corner of the photo um of
like him in the process of creating a
piece of artwork
um and he started these everydays back
in 2007 where he created a new piece of
artwork every day since 2007 and he
hasn't missed a single day and it's
actually uh pretty crazy how he's kept
this up and you can see like
um artworks that he's created during
certain anniversaries like when his
daughter was born when he was sick but
even throughout all these different
milestones in his life he's still never
missed a day of creating artwork so
that's kind of his claim to fame so he
was really famous for creating his
everyday series but
uh he was never really able to monetize
that he's like he would create a piece
of artwork posted on Instagram uh and
like he would get a big Instagram
following but
um no one was really paying for it uh so
instead uh he had to kind of make a
living through doing other jobs like
um creating graphics for concert visuals
so like when a big uh DJ or EDM artist
uh tours uh they need uh big concert
visuals behind them and he'll create
those visuals or uh he'd also do other
um commission artworks for clients uh
that was also another way that artists
uh during the digital artists during the
time made a living
um and that all changed when he decided
to Mint nfts so you know it was back in
October 2020 where you know people
learned about nfts and minted his very
first piece uh was a piece called
politics is [__]
um and you know this is a piece uh
mentioned on Nifty Gateway it was only
addition of 100 and as kind of a joke uh
he
set the mint price to a dollar so
obviously they got sold out in less than
a second
um and if you're one of the lucky 100
people that was able to snag uh this
piece uh today it'd be worth um the
floor price right now is 85eath which is
about 130 000.
um so that's a pretty good return for
being like super fast at clicking the
buy button and
uh I guess I also want to talk about
Nifty Gateway where
um you know today I've talked about
you know one-of-one arts art like on
super rare where it's only artists
selling one piece or like a collection
of like say 10 000 like generative
pieces but Nifty Gateway uh popularized
a new way of artists uh selling Works uh
which are called additions and open
editions so addition can be
um say edition of uh five or addition of
a hundred and it's like the same uh JPEG
but that way you have like five
different collectors or 100 different
collectors who can collect your piece
and like that helps an artist gets more
buy-in and like a bigger community of
collectors and there's also something
called open editions which is
um kind of unlimited mints so an artist
will say okay for the next uh 10 minutes
anyone can mint my piece and after that
it's like uh done forever
um and that was a really popular way for
a bunch of like thousands of collectors
to get a really cheap piece from their
favorite artist without having to pay a
lot to buy a one of one
um
so after that October sale uh people did
a couple more drops you know a mix of
additions one of ones open editions but
things didn't really get super crazy
until uh March 2021 and this is when
people did the auction at Christie's
through our platform called a makers
place and you know this is a collage of
the first 5 000 everydays pieces so like
I said earlier uh peoples had created an
artwork new piece of art from 2007 all
the way to 2021 without missing a single
day and this is a collage of every
single one of those artworks and he
decided to auction this off at
Christie's and there was a lot of press
coverage at the time because uh there
was already a bidding war going on and
uh and I I was watching this live and it
was crazy as the auction was closing
um the
kind of the bids uh jumped from like a
couple million and then it went to like
20 million and then it went to 50
million and then finally
um a collector uh paid 69 million for
this piece of artwork and immediately uh
that kind of blew up the entire art
World
um it got on like the front page of like
every single newspaper
um and this is also the sixth highest
artwork sale of all time by a living
artist
um and you know people's in the kind of
the same names as
these Legends like you know Jasper Johns
Damien Hurst you can see Jeff Coons
um these like very very big name artists
in the traditional art world and like
he's up there with all of them and last
thing I'll say is the collector's name
is uh medicovan uh he's an Indian
billionaire uh crypto billionaire and
he's been collecting art for a very long
time he doesn't not only owns this one
piece but he also owns all of people's
one of ones so he's the largest people
collector also has an nft fund and uh
he's he's not looking to sell this so
he's just kind of patiently waiting and
thinks that this is a historical piece
of all right do you raise your hand
yeah I'm just curious I have a question
what would be the motivation for someone
to buy this but
um yeah yeah so the question is like
what's the motivation for someone to buy
this well if you think it's like a piece
of like art history like significance uh
then uh you would pay like a stupidly
high price because you would think that
in like 50 years from now it will be
worth even more
um and that's also like how kind of the
traditional art World works is kind of
the most expensive the most valuable
things are worth paying up a lot of
money for because those are the ones
that are going to be worth even more so
basically if you bought a Picasso uh or
you bought Andy Warhol like 50 years ago
those are the ones that are worth like
people at the time kind of laughed at
you if you paid those prices but those
are the pieces that uh accumulated value
rather than like other artists so that's
kind of I think what he's thinking here
where uh people is going to be the Andy
Warhol of the internet generation uh and
that's why it's worth paying a lot for
this because this is going to end up in
museums this is going to end up in our
history textbooks you know 30 to 50
years from now
um cool so you know this uh sale
happened uh you know and as I said uh
crypto art becomes mainstream so you
know he's it's on the headlines of you
know New York Times uh you know people
appears on Joe Rogan on uh Jimmy Fallon
uh he's like basically turns into a
celebrity overnight because you know
this artist that was kind of living a
semi like paycheck to paycheck but like
a very modest life just doing commission
for clients all of a sudden like Pockets
69 million from one sale and like that's
like completely changed his life and
really
um
legitimizes the entire crypto r nft
space
so you know really after that
um that was a turning point for crypto
art
um so I want to kind of continue with
some data so this is
um
kind of a volume graph of crypto or um
sales uh and you can see the first split
was in March 2021 which was when uh
people did that sale and then the next
flip I think was in August 2021 that's
when art blocks went crazy although that
was the generative art platform I talked
about earlier and that's when the floor
price of like ringers for denzas all
this generative are pieces you know shot
up from like sub one eth to like 40 60
eat or like kind of absurd amounts uh
because collectors saw those as super
valuable
um obviously it's come down since
um because of like there was a lot of
speculative froth at the time
um but as you can see as the volumes
plateau uh kind of where it bottoms out
is higher than like the previous
um before crypto art really became a
thing and that's always healthy because
as long as the trough is higher than the
previous Peak you know it kind of
mirrors the history of like
cryptocurrency Cycles
um where kind of each boom is higher
than the previous bust and like so on so
forth as the space kind of has these
speculative frenzies but over the long
run it legitimizes
and the last thing I want to say is the
total Market crap of cap of crypto R is
only 0.2 percent of the total market cap
of cryptocurrencies and you know the
reason you know we as a fund we're
making a big bet in nfts is we think
that percentage is going to grow
significantly over time that you know
crypto art nfts is going to disrupt
culture and the total market cap of
culture is you know much much bigger
than like of non-fungible assets it's
much much bigger than total market cap
of fungible assets
um
and the other thing I want to talk about
is uh kind of this this is a screenshot
from my website cryptoart.io but you can
see
um who the top 10 artists here so you
have you know podcast number one uh
people's number two snowfro who's the
founder of art blocks just number three
uh you have Tyler Hobbs x copy Dimitri
cherniak uh these are some of the
artists I've mentioned earlier and you
can see the total value of their
artworks are in the tens of millions to
hundreds of millions uh and it's this
kind of all came out of nowhere uh in
just a couple of years uh where in the
traditional art world uh these would be
like pretty absurd numbers uh but it
shows how you know there's a lot of
collector demand interest in crypto art
and that's why uh the total value of
these artworks are worth the way worth
how much they're worth
um so we you know we kind of talked
about the past and the present of Crypt
art so I just want to talk a bit about
the future of crypto art
um so kind of my first uh prediction for
what's going to happen is you know
traditional art institutions are gonna
uh start curating crypto art Collections
and feature them in uh kind of museums
uh in in galleries so this is actually
an ongoing exhibit right now
um at the MoMA in New York um it's by a
generative art by an artist named Rafiq
anadol um it's this is called
unsupervised which his name is
collection I mean I think Rafiq I
believe is the first crypto artist to be
featured in Moma and I think there's
going to be many many more uh artworks
that are featured in Moma uh this is
just kind of you know a temporary
exhibition I think the MoMA is going to
look to acquire uh nfts and crypto as as
part of their permanent collection and
you know that might require selling some
of the existing pieces but I think that
trend is going to happen in the next a
decade or two
and you know I talked a little bit about
this earlier but you know throughout my
entire talk I was mainly focused on
crypto R in the history of crypto art
but I think nfts and non-fungible assets
is a powerful medium and that's not just
going to disrupt nfts but also pretty
much every vertical of like of culture
and like Creator entertainment industry
so you know we talk about art there's
also music there's photography
um there's gaming
um there's kind of like virtual real
estate uh there's like kind of the list
goes on and on in each vertical is like
a multi-multi-billion dollar industry uh
and because of that because the market
is so big I think
um it will support like not only you
know billion dollar companies but also
individual nfts uh that are worth like
much much more uh millions billions uh
who knows
great so that's really all I got
um here's my contact info and happy to
answer any questions
[Applause]
sure sure
yeah
sure
um so a major theme so thank you for the
talk today
um a major theme of the course is sort
of both the history of blockchain and
web3 and then also where it's headed so
I have two questions for you
um the first one is that a lot of
blockchain companies and ideas right now
are still on the experimental stage very
much like we had with the internet in
the 1990s and that applies to
cryptocurrencies that applies to defy
that applies to nfts to crypto art
um so as you look at sort of trends that
have happened here and sort of the
history that you explain
what do you think the major areas in
crypto art are going to be in the future
where it actually plays sort of a
transformational role because
traditional art will still have a role
too
and then the next question is nft
technology is pretty nascent and
especially you know for example when
metadata gets stored off chain
um and so what sort of technological
advances do you think need to happen to
support those future Trends in crypto
art that you think are going to happen
yeah yeah so first question
um
I think crypto R is just going to be
like another
um category in like kind of art history
textbooks that we'll talk like another
movement is like you know you had like I
don't know like Rococo and like
neoclassicism and like expressionism
abstract expressionism and like crypto
is just going to be like the next thing
and like you know each of these
categories you had uh like millions of
dollars of like collector money poured
into like collecting like who are the
Blue Chip artists of each movement and I
think crypto Arts is like a continuation
of that so I don't think it's gonna like
replace traditional art it'll just be a
continuation of that where I'll draw in
new collectors or like existing
collectors will want to add crypto art
to their existing collections uh in
terms of your second questions of like
what technology is missing in like nfts
uh you did like hit like a really good
point is that you know nft data metadata
right now is like very centralized and
like that's kind of the dirty secret of
the nft space is
um kind of where are these jpegs stored
well it's just like a URL two it's like
it's a URL basically and oftentimes that
URL is just like a link to some AWS
servers so whatever company is like
hosting that server if they go offline
tomorrow then you won't be able to
render your nfts because uh it'll just
get like a like a 404 not found so there
are there are companies working on this
like RV R weave is one
um where they're working on uh
decentralized file storage you know
filecoin is another one that you've
probably heard of
um basically it means that if the
company hosting the nft metadata goes
down like the nft doesn't disappear
automatically because there's always
someone else that's hosting that's
replicating backing up like the metadata
in the image
um so I guess just to follow up uh
microphone
okay so I guess a follow-up do you think
you know when I when I bring in this
technology angle
um the metadata is a thing but do you
think there are structurally
bigger things that need to change in
nfts so
um you know sort of like we need a new
EIP to have nft version two and what
would that look like uh so you know I
talked about 721 there's also EIP 1155
it's the other version a version of nfts
that allows for bundles
um I know there's a lot of new nft
um eips are floated around there's one
on royalties that's uh pretty popular I
don't remember the exact EIP number
yes so yeah something like that but uh
yeah there's a lot of different
proposals up there
yeah thank you okay
I thought I know that you just mentioned
that um
being just a continuation of like art
history right
um well you know thinking back on art
history a lot of the conversation when
those artists were alive but it wasn't
about necessarily a monetary value of
what it was worth the larger audiences
right
um and so you know I was just hoping you
could comment on the fact that it seems
like a lot of the conversations
surrounding this particular artwork
isn't necessarily about the beauty or
what it captures about today's age or
cult you know culture but and thinking
on and really in art history a lot of
the artists they weren't Rich you know
while they were alive right
um so I was just hoping you could
comment a little bit about
um about how it can be a how it can be
thought of as similar to the past to art
history when and really in reality it
really seems a lot to be a lot more
about the money than it was before yeah
I think in crypto just like the feedback
cycle is like super super short it's
like I always joke that like uh you know
one year in crypto is like 10 years in
like any other industry and like I think
that's why
um artists
um like there's like so much talk about
money going on around because you know
the artists are still alive uh as these
artworks are appreciating like it's not
like it takes tens hundreds of years for
like that phenomenon to happen
um in terms of like you know like
comments on like Beauty like how it
reflects our culture I think like that's
why people is like so valuable is like
he's kind of like Andy warhol-esque
where if you see like a lot of his
artworks uh it's like really like
commentary on like politics like you
know Trump Biden elections
um I I could probably pull up I could do
like a Google image search and like show
you stuff it works I don't have wait
actually I do
maybe it'll be cool to show you like
just uh
nsw but uh in people's oh oh it's people
crap I think
uh yeah see some of this stuff or
anything yeah so some of the stuff is
like probably not safe for work
um but yeah you can see stuff uh yeah
there's like Pac-Man's there's like a
lot of Pop Culture you know there's like
Elon riding a doge you know this is when
during the Dogecoin like craze so
um yeah I guess you can say that like
crypto Arts like a commentary of like
our culture and you know people like the
stuff because it's like fun pop art ish
yes
hi so um I'm a double major in CS and
art practice and I also sell and share
my artwork online so your talk was like
super interesting and relevant to me
um I'm just wondering kind of about your
personal background and motivation like
in all of the web three space why
specifically crypto art is like that the
area that you're interested in like what
makes creation and art your calling uh
well it's I'm not just interested in
crypto R I'll first say that so like
kind of my background as VC um like
we're pretty sector agnostic we invest
in like not just art but like defy
infrastructure like really anything
that's Cutting Edge and new and web3
crypto that's like pushing the space
forward
um I guess I got into crypto R because I
was kind of early to it and I really
like the people in the community and
like at the time like you know back in
like 2019 2020 it wasn't really big so
it was just I liked it because like the
people were cool and then then the money
came and then that kind of changed
everything
cool
okay thank you so I'm really concerned
about this recent this scam of the FTX
because personally I am also a startup
in web3 I also I might start up in
number three I'm from Davis lab so I
just motivated by David but my point is
I think the auditing should serve as a
very very important
with a very important in your in every
web stream startup but you know these
kind of FTX they have very shitty
auditing system that's the reason why
they are a scam that's the reason why
they make this industry looks very
terrible
so my reason my question is what kind of
auditing system do you have do you work
with Deloitte or
on other PWC something like that well
the problem with FTX is like
it's like if you cook the books you cook
the books it's like
the FTX scam had like nothing to do with
like the what they were actually selling
like it had nothing nothing to do with
like cryptocurrencies like they could be
selling like beanie babies but like at
the end of the day if like you make up
the numbers on the spreadsheet is like
that's just fraud
um
I guess I I'm actually not sure which
Auditors FTX use I don't think it was a
big four but
um because that that issue
no okay
um yeah actually the crypto is the
secondary property makes the auditing
extremely hard to audit what kind of
blockchain or Bitcoin
or friends in the Lord she says that
actually it's very hard for them they
even need to know what what street is
about what blockchain is about to make
sure that we can audit because they only
have experience in auditing web pickup
and my point is I don't want your
company to become a scam like FTX
there's no warning to you
yeah well I actually the another thing
I'll say is like this is like kind of
the problem with centralized exchanges
because as centralized exchanges at the
end of day like are more like web 2
companies uh and like this is why D5 is
important is because you don't need
Auditors and d5s like all the tokens are
stored like say in this smart contract
this address on chain you can just see
that the assets are there uh whereas if
you're you know hiding behind uh say no
FTX or you know binance or coinbase like
one of these companies centralized
exchanges then you're gonna have to rely
on trusted third parties as auditors the
last question
are you aware do you want the microphone
my son is loving I don't think they're
recording can hear you no worries okay
it's just a private question so am I
just wanting this question do you do you
know perfect work I think you must know
Prof work right
yeah Bitcoin yeah do you know the
optimal strategy after work is
centralization
yes yes
YouTube YouTube also know that people
will sacrifice their expectations in
trade of the small variance
uh I I don't really understand that
question my point is the optimal policy
to win in the proof work setting is the
centralization
and you cannot say hey we are doing the
decentralization so we are good
I want you to rethink that the
centralization can still happen in even
in a different setting and this will
lead to lots of problems like the scx I
want you to think this is always
centralization risk and everything yes
so that's the reason why I hope you guys
can make your hands dirty to go to the
theoretical Foundation like es374
okay go deep do not
be
it's like this yeah I took David C's
class actually oh I ordered it because
it was
um it was after I graduated yeah yeah
thank you yeah we have one time for one
more question
all right okay
literally related uh but
um I saw on the top you have like Dow
guides and like Dow tooling and I'm
really curious sorry no this is uh oh I
know okay then maybe not not be
connected at all
um but I'm curious if you think a lot of
the Dow spaces are going to be centered
around nfts as a way to establish
membership or tiered membership yes
um and yeah just your opinions on that
and what you see yes uh actually one of
the most OG dials is called Flamingo Dao
um they were like one of the first art
collector dolls and they bought a bunch
of early of art blocks pieces like super
early on that's actually like one of my
biggest regrets is like a lot of my
friends who join were convincing me to
join but like I was kind of too slow and
like lazy and then then kind of art
blocks took off and the rest was history
but I think like collector Dallas is uh
gonna be like in a big Trend over the
next few years um it's like mainly like
group purchases of
um I like expensive nfts and like
collector gals are kind of like you know
nft like collectives investment funds
and like where people can like pull
their money together so they can buy uh
like a zombie punk or like a people one
of one uh so I think that's a a big
trend
yeah or like follow-up question yeah I I
guess I was curious
I guess I was curious too in terms of
like showing Dow membership so rather
than like currently a lot of your tiers
within Dows are like based off of
tokenomics yeah so so but since a lot of
tokens are being scrutinized legally
um and a lot more Securities it's
difficult for dows
to uh
you know to start creating a lot of
their own tokens and so would do Vision
a lot of these Dows using nfts and a lot
of tool Dow tooling shifting towards
like erc721s and to
be centered around nft members rather
than tokenomics yeah that's one of the
use cases of nft I know the use case I
didn't talk about is like access pass
it's like token getting token gating
access uh where you know a dow can have
say addition of like 10 nfts and like
that's like kind of the most like gold
standard like the gold tier where like
it's the most exclusive and you might
have an addition of like 100 that's like
the silver tier like so on so forth
there's
um you know projects doing that uh
there's also like kind of artists um
like I guess I'm really into like like
EDM so like Armin Van Buren's like
artists who like dropped a big like nft
um you know token gated access like
Discord so
um it's kind of like what you described
you have like these different tier
membership and each that gives you you
know certain privileges like like
exclusive access to certain concerts
like backstage passes things like that
thank you
all right that's our wrap for today's
class thank you everybody for coming and
lastly give Richard great thank you you
guys